I know your family's waiting I know it's
an important day for God's sakes you
zerah don't words I'm sorry cinema snob
is just I'm so excited it's the Star
Wars holiday sequel we're totally
reckoning the problems on the last one
we're not going anywhere this we outrun
that giant slice of pizza why don't you
just jump to Lightspeed that's always
the answer
oh yeah why is it I was take me so long
to remember that
critic we're home yep the same old
coloring book cover that we're used to
come on I want you to meet my extended
family for Hanukkah oh they're not a
bunch of wookies like in the last
special are there no I told you snap
we're doing something completely
different this time here's a Jefferson
Starship hear me over now
now loose accessor and watch this when I
go into dinners so what do we watch
holiday specials oh no no no we partake
in the most classic of Hanukkah
traditions we just sit around and
watched up it has absolutely nothing to
do with the holiday whatsoever look the
force awakens is on I see what you did
there it's very simple the highly
anticipated sequel to the now poorly
named sci-fi trilogy is here Star Wars
The Force awakens can it make up for the
Sitz of the past will there be a special
edition where CG characters are replaced
with puppets and most importantly will
it lead to even more holiday specials
more come on Halloween Easter would you
love to see how Jar Jar celebrates Black
History Month rather drive with Jake
Lloyd this is the force awakens so it
starts off with hold on a second but
what's somebody out there can't read and
how would they know to click on the
video it starts off with a rebel spy
giving secret information to a little
droid just before stormtroopers come in
and separate them wait that sounds
eerily familiar road chip had the same
plot really
who knows you'll never see it to find
out instead the Empire this time it's
the first order which is just another
name for Empire
pretty much as one of their leaders and
kylo Ren tells them to put the pilot
name PO on the ship and kill everybody
else put the pilot name po on my ship
and kill everybody else especially max
von sydow this would be zero zero one
yeah what's Harvey Corbin doing in this
oh he's a robot that lets us know when a
good actor is completely wasted in a
role number two six five max von sydow
gone but not unhooked often does that
happen a lot in this movie does the Jedi
menorah have nine lightsabers but one
stormtrooper named Finn is shocked that
being a psychotic killer means being a
psychotic killer so he breaks Po out but
gets shot down to planet not Tatooine
where Finn presumes Poe's dead as the
ship sinks into the sand and blows up
perhaps it was allergic to sand it is
very coarse rough and irritating and it
gets everywhere this is why we meet ray
a scavenger waiting for her family to
return who comes across the Droid named
bb-8 well as you an adorable soccer ball
the stormtroopers Bakshi gunto but the
nut Empire fights the joy to causing her
to run into thin and the two of them
team up trying to escape they come
across the Millennium Falcon which is
confused for spread metal it belongs in
a museum and they take off in it seeing
how apparently none of these ships
require keys of any kind of course all
the Thai fighters missed them because
only the drug is a soldier's pilot those
things and they escape into space
because the galaxy is such a small place
they bump into Han Solo and Chewbacca
you're wait a minute what's with the
animation all the sudden well through
certain camera lenses some people look
like poorly animated cartoon characters
uh not happening wait a minute how is it
possible you're watching the special
with me that's your biggest question
you're not concerned why the jar jar's
are watching gay acrobatic holograms you
just don't understand Chanukah yes
because you've never explained it to me
it's not something you explain it's
something you feel I feel like a scotch
right now Plaza so rain Finn explained
their situation and soullow agrees to
help them get the Drake to the not
rentals after he's attacked by some
people yields money to just hired here
until this point was detour blows over
pointless detour that ties in perfectly
with the time to watch the human
pornography's I have for some reason Oh
play laughs ah how is that even possible
well this should fittingly explain how
pointless this scene is Angry Men
wanting their money
giant octopuses they come out of nowhere
hmm
none of its tie-in to the story
oh yeah but still shorter than the
opening of Return of the Jedi
oh sure this isn't the porno version of
Star Wars now I think the plot would
actually be more focused so kylo Ren
talks to Supreme Leader Snoke and holy
shit what the hell is that oh my god
that's the new adverb he's gigantic Holy
Smoke
imagine the possibilities you can do it
Supreme Leader I'm sorry we have to talk
to you Vietnam cost-effective gigantic
hologram oh that's what making me think
you were awesome well who knows maybe it
still has a pretty good design I thought
I said no more cartoons in this actually
I think that's supposed to look
realistic yeah remember that cheap-ass
alien from Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
he's your Emperor now except somehow he
looks even faker not to mention a
whopping seven lines from the ACTA
you're never allowed to see act Andy
Serkis how even the name Snoke it sounds
like an 80s cartoon about a bunch of
colorful creatures that live underwater
but he does at least let out this
important bit of information by the way
how is your father han Solo
are you alright
hey what else get it you're so dead five
just now not really in fact I'm getting
more of a two more movies vibe to be
honest yeah it's probably just you
that's exactly what I'm afraid of
you
phlex are finding out the villain has a
father-son relationship with one of the
good guys we go to a Cantina where a ton
of weird aliens hang out okay none of
this is really about having been done
before
oh I see where you're going with this
I'm Bea Arthur welcome to my watering
hole please tell me no more about your
watering hole I wouldn't talk Eraserhead
all right settle down you're not even a
real fighter you want us all to run so
what if I do
Finn don't ever think that only fools
and cowards run now we hear you might
have something that could lead us to
Luke Skywalker sure do good you run oh
that was easy blow em up anyone left on
time for dinner
the Empire is shutting us down time
and Fred go say goodbye friend
instead friend
I'm alright kid so ray is captured and
interrogated by kylo Ren only to have
ray interrogate him why do you seek
Skywalker why do you seek Skywalker
he's a jerky uncle who didn't let me
play with the dark side yeah you were a
force I do well then you will leave me
with a weak minded stormtrooper so that
I can escape huh joke's on you that's
what I was gonna do anyway hey
release me okay meanwhile Finn meets up
with his old friend oh hey surprised I'm
alive no I saw him the trailer well Solo
meets up with his old flame general Leia
Leia I saw our son han I know they're
still good in him he just Jackson
Pollack the cantina with a bunch of
space Nazis he's a little past grounding
at this point please promise me that
you'll try and win him back promise
alright I'll try to win him back
also can you fill out these insurance
forms for good and close out these bank
accounts also wear this red shirt I
really think it screams you some Abrams
move a solo an offense sneak aboard
their Bey's and forced the captain of
the stormtroopers to lower the shield
lower the shield's another garbage chute
on seeing Wetteland crispy performance I
think this one speaks for itself they
wanted to Rey but also went to kylo Ren
who's solo decides he's going to
confront her besides I'm going to
confront have I ever told you that you
like a mentor to me Christ I have no
chance
so solo approaches his son who takes his
mask off to reveal that he's actually a
pretty good looking guy who why the hell
does he wear a mask well the dark side
does seem to be anti pretty people son I
know we haven't seen each other in years
and there's people pointing guns at us
and I know I've ever given you any new
reasons to come back
but I'd like you to come back before I
answer like you just take another few
steps forward oh sure your mother misses
you son I miss you too
and if you could forget for a minute
that both the writer and I wanted me to
die and return to the Jedi well it would
be great if you could see what a
surprise
I love you so after the old mentor is
killed a bunch of ships fly in to stop
the giant planet destroying ball that's
about to blow up the base where Leia is
while a lightsaber duel takes place with
a villain who seems torn between good
and evil none of this is sounding
familiar in the slightest like oh hey
you're the one who keeps living in the
past having harvey korman in drag teach
the dreidel spin spin spin spin oh 3,000
years of beautiful tradition from Moses
to Sandy Koufax you're goddamn right I'm
livin in the past oh come off it critic
you're not even fucking Jewish man I
converted to Chewbacca is in the minute
I married mrs. ja ja Raven dreidel
dreidel I made you welcome home this
does bring up a good point though as
similar as these scenes are to the Past
there's not as much investment in them
we care for the desktop battles in the
other films because we knew Luke
Skywalker
we knew Lando Calrissian and we knew the
emotional stakes here we have Poe in the
space battle who hasn't had a lot of
screen time and we don't really know the
consequences of either base blowing up
the bad guys always seem to make a
bigger base after one is destroyed and
we're not sure the majority of rebels
are on the planet this time or if
they're spread out even the lightsaber
duel seems kind of underwhelming we only
have one scene where these two have any
real connection and well it's a good
scene it's not really enough for a
climax with the other ones they talked
and discuss their history while fighting
your powers are weak old man I was the
student but now I'm the master you are
not a Jedi obi-wan never told you what
happened to your father
here it's join me yeah and that's it you
get more dialog out of a mine screenplay
no please when is JJ Abrams ever
repeated anything in a sci-fi fridge I
can't even finish that the fighters
destroy the base causing kylo and Rey to
be some
here's to figuring out how we're related
I say cousin idling who should that be
related to late oh no oh come on
everyone else is related so the nakta
star is blown up raid travels to see
Luke Skywalker and she meets him on top
of a mountain where she hands him back
his lights
so it was good but did it really have to
be so similar to the other movies nah
come on if you honestly see a connection
between an evil dictatorship chasing a
droid with secret plans landing on a
desert planet where a wide-eyed youth
comes across it follows in the footsteps
of a mentor who has a connection to the
villain being controlled by a shadowy
overlord only to lose that mentor while
discovering a surprise father-son
relationship leading to a battle against
a giant round weapon that destroys
planets and is about to destroy the base
of a heroic resistance but is stopped
just in time resulting in our main
character leaving to train with an old
wise master from the past well then
that's just silly I just don't get it
why would they after all these years do
something very similar but screws move
but muscle Kappa no how about oh thank
heavens that finally paused or s are
your real voice oh no no no that's just
a phase my race goes through you see we
all start off whiny and annoying but
then we hit a certain age where we
become quite charming and brilliant the
rest of my family were hit it soon
enough but until then I thank you for
indulging in all of my insufferable
antics no problem now lets us prepare
for our wonderful holiday oh dear there
appears to be feces on the floor but a
step around that well that actually made
things a lot better
well yeah trying to make up for the sins
of the past holiday special so that's
why you did so many things that the
other one did exactly if I want to move
forward with more specials I have to
prove I can do a regular one okay so I
stick to the formula only this time I do
it a lot better
shit this is a metaphor isn't pretty
much I guess it does kind of make sense
when you really think about it after so
many years of people hating the prequels
these filmmakers had a lot to prove so
they had to demonstrate that they could
do something that looks and feels like
star wars before they can move forward
with anything
sure a lot of its on repeat but it's
done in such an entertaining a whimsical
way that it's still really enjoyable and
who knows maybe the new stuff as you've
gotten more attention in this film will
get attention in the next film and
besides they've done practically every
plot thread the other movies have done
there's not many left leaving it open to
new ideas and upcoming films it's not a
classic but it doesn't need to be yet
it's the reintroduction of an old fred
who's taken a beating and just needed to
show that he's gonna be okay before he
accomplishes better things
well since knob Wilson but Critic I
still don't understand what is the true
meaning of America well just touch the
magic ball and I'll show you you're all
like family to me just touch a goddamn
ball
laya you made it oh I wouldn't miss this
holiday for the world Leia my friend
here would like to know the true meaning
of her Mecca would you kindly explain it
to him of course
week
you
are you gonna take it or what today what
you need to hold it for a month a month
but next month is January you know what
that means
Shamu on ma
keep it up
what No
at the end of the day you're still not
as big a disappointment is mutt Williams
Oh Becca
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this is one that I've know
about for a while giving money to and
it's really really good for some reasons
I've never brought up before and I don't
know why but I'm doing it now because it
definitely deserves the acknowledgement
it is Mercy Corps this is a humanitarian
global organization that goes around and
specializes in saving people in every
meaning of the word they feed people
they go fix infrastructures that need
fixing they get people water they
rebuild places have been destroyed
whether from war or natural disasters or
whatever they'll do tech startups
they'll fix bridges that are broken even
land rights this is an organization that
does everything everything they do is
just focused on making people better and
trying to help them out and going to
places where they have a ton of
disadvantages and making it so that they
can be strong again and the nice thing
is they don't just stick to one location
they travel everywhere all around the
world 42 countries all together it's
amazing how much work they put into this
it's kind of like a team of superman's
all they do is go around and just try to
help people by any means necessary I
have no idea how they do it or how they
can get all these people together to do
all these various things but they do and
it's phenomenal
definitely definitely take the time to
check out their website look at their
YouTube page as well see all the good
that they're doing and see if you're
willing to donate because man they do it
all and all that they do is amazing go
check it out show your support